536 so as you know Hospitality it's the
backbone of Las Vegas but the pandemic
really took its toll Culinary Academy
starting dates numbers increase once
again but enrollment is still down
Lauren Grady joins us live from the
academy in North Las Vegas to talk about
their newest program and job placement
there Lauren good morning
good morning yes there are 16 very
different programs here at The Culinary
Academy of Las Vegas and they're all
they're all very Hands-On they have
everything from Food Service of course
to Hotel maintenance even building
replicas of Caesar hotel rooms plus the
full service West Side Bistro that is
entirely student-run they have a 90
percent job placement rate and they work
to get their students jobs through
Partnerships with local unions and major
strip properties like MGM Resorts Caesar
Caesar's entertainment and the win
the multiple programs that we have for
all different varieties of jobs in the
food service industry sets them up for
Success the biggest thing that we offer
here is the instructional program and
then right away they get into the
operation
now their newest program is the culinary
apprenticeship program it gives students
the chance to learn while earning a wage
plus union members can qualify for free
refresher courses now back out here live
coming up in the next half hour the CEO
tells us more about their post-pandemic
Outlook back to you guys